all right for people joining this
livestream we are talking about ways to
use ways to do reinforcement learning
using external reinforcement learning
platforms so um
Sebastian do you want to just go ahead
and some of this so just for the context
for people tuning in we basically we
added supports to neural networks for 12
that allows them to do reinforcement
learning training and we want to have
some examples in the documentation in 12
to actually show how to how to do that
and the sort of analog of datasets for
reinforcement learning our environments
and at the moment we don't have any
environments in the system and so we
decided that it makes sense to add some
environments for 12 so if we can
actually show off the rise in the
environments are being added as
effectively devices yes so there was a
debate about exactly how to expose this
to use in top level and the device
framework seems like a pretty good fit
so
yeah so here's a very simple example so
in this case there's a family there's
gonna be different families of
environments in this case these are our
own internal built in environments but
always work as opposed to other kinds of
environments that require setup and
whatnot
so this creates the environments we
watch with the system model of people to
make any of these not yet it seems like
an obvious thing to do are they even
aware of this idea I have not talked to
them at all about this but we should
talk to them that we could make all
kinds of cool things I mean probably
even out our examples of system model
our system model examples probably
already have things in there that would
be usable yes million that's my list
good this is probably like a toilet
posts tall thing yeah definitely it's
not gonna happen today okay let's read
the current state okay so it's some
state that it's gots it's not clear
whether it should be both the states and
also whether it's ended or not so
basically for the people who haven't
seen much reinforcement learning often
states for example like let's say be
playing a game there's some end
condition to the game and it's useful to
know when that end condition is hit so
you often want the states and you want
the end condition yeah okay go ahead so
for some types of environments it makes
sense that you can visualize them or
render them in this case the state
corresponds to a pole so it's a very
simple thing it's like this this is some
sort of cot that's on a on a track and
this pole needs needs to balance so the
task in this case will be to keep this
pull-up right random action yeah so
random action gives you an action this
also that means what is the zero mean so
zero usually doesn't matter you know
like it's not user readable like open a
I Jim for example they just have numbers
what actions are in this case I think
zero is left and then yeah so this is a
curry we should we should be a tongue
you know of the symbols symbols left and
right if that's what we could do it yeah
okay okay so basically we could take an
action so this sometimes is called step
sometimes it's called action so this
returns what a fact also act as is that
so normally it will be we be saying left
right yeah exactly this might be exactly
as we left saw Rex
this gives you back a state
representation and this is usually what
you train on for you know your agents
will learn on the state's whether it's
ended or not and some rewards that
you've gotten so in this case the reward
is one if it doesn't collapse and in
this case death means past like some
angle like this is not a goal that's
used and all of these things always need
a way to reset them as well so it puts
it back to some initial state all right
okay so what do we have in our initial
collection of these environments so the
initial connection is we have a we have
a link to open item which has a lot of
environments but which often require
complicated setup if I'm understanding
correctly correct so it requires user
setup in Python but for now we've only
got one environment here and for that
for 12 that's fine I think because we
can at least have this environment this
is sort of like the endless stove of
reinforcement learning environments so
where did we get where do we get the
graphic design of that thing from ah
that was my personal graphic design
during the summer school why don't we
why don't we just ask the design group
to just try and make that a little bit
nicer with something other than a
primary blue and things should be super
fast um like open a also has a very
design for that no is it the same Christ
so they have their own design for that
show that too okay one cool thing is
with a random agent so if you have this
this method for random sampling you know
you just open a device list animates
create table of steps and then run it
and then obviously the random agent is
not going to do very well so it's like
somewhat balancers and then it just
falls down okay and just one more thing
so because
external evaluators broken I can't
actually run this right now but
basically this was what happened with a
few days ago build so the same thing you
can do with Soto did that device open is
implemented internally using device but
using external evaluate that correct
ranks that creates an external
evaluation session that you send
commands to so it's a state from why
that image at device execute wasn't that
render you had a render action didn't
you okay so so this is where okay that's
a very good question
so basically rendering is something
that's open a I it does the they don't
have a rendering function that produces
like a nice picture for you class that
we can get back with external evaluate
so what this game does it has an actual
image as the state so you can render
that state directly but there is a way
of that why isn't the presentation just
the the image then it's a new mercury so
idea is we're not going to curate what
their state representations are is that
the idea yeah so if they use numeric or
they use numpy arrays and we're just
gonna use the net analog of that numeric
arrays and that's perfectly you know you
can feed that into learning algorithms
perfectly fine but you can interpret
that as an image sometimes okay but so
how many different this whatever River
raid vv0
how many different things do they have
in their gym so they've got it's a good
question I think it's something like
maybe 40 or 50 environments okay the
tower game likes to go to a seaman was
saying it will shock me but will return
an image as a state in that case I would
still be quite faithful to what environm
and probably nicer to me little bit
easier to play with I mean especially
since we have lots of image processing
we have lots of encoders for the neuron
that's for images and so on curators
right because this is it's it's can we
be bothered to curate them it's really
the question is if they add another you
know this presumably doesn't know about
what that second string is it just sends
that second string to the open a I Jim
correct precisely yeah so just so I
think we so that means at the end that I
think we can't know whether a newly
online environment has a numerical ray
that represents an image or doesn't
represent an image so therefore I think
it's best to leave it as a numeric array
we can have a curated version of this
you know if we have a version that we
can ship of one of these Atari games for
example then by all means we can have
from you know a thing that's fully fully
curated and gives an image there so also
just mention that you know one of the
problems with this so this is a way of
seeing what the observation space is so
you can ask open air gym to give you
back like a symbolic representation of
the observation space and what is it
chemical code so in typical case were
like an image for example be they've got
a box space which is basically a
hypercube and they say what the limits
are so in this case you know but do they
say it's supposed to be an image no they
don't and the problem also is that's
what makes it even harder that's you
know like if there's multiple channels
to the image
sometimes there's interleaving goes to
true or false yeah okay so fine so
that's something which we can you know
people can document externally but we're
not going to you know maybe we can give
specific examples of this but we're not
going to be able to do it in general
because things can be added and you know
who knows yeah exactly so I think it's
better just to have a keen like this
right one thing that there will be for
this though is that if there's an action
like this is zero
there is for the gym the rendering
happens when you take it in action in
the hour step in the gym you can ask
them open the item to render this thing
in a separate window that Python creates
oh gods like I don't know that's the
total mess I wouldn't bother
so that's guess what we can't see that
because it's not being shared yeah and I
consider that because I can't run it'll
vary but it's broken
okay well fine I'd be able to thrilled
to have that not work because I think
it's a total mess I think I mean it's
nice to have a filter to ask you to it's
very nice because you can see the thing
training in real time as it's doing it
and we should be feeding that back into
the notebook okay
might be away but I don't know how to do
that yes well I guarantee that this is
gonna break but I mean if you know if
it's just running some random external
program I guess it's okay I mean given
that it's in the device framework I
think one can expect it's running some
random external thing no fine
I have no you know I'm not an enthusiast
okay but yeah otherwise there's no way
of viewing this stuff often so in this
case in states but if the state has
there was ever Ram states which is like
a representation of the RAM in the game
yeah is much smaller and then you can't
visualize it at all if you don't have
that rendering thing why I mean just
pull it back and then and visualize it I
mean what what's the difference I don't
understand because the RAM states that's
not enough to visualize it what's not so
so in this case the state is so for this
game his River Edge version 0 but
there's also something I think river a
dram version 0 ok which gives like a
list of numbers that represent some
state in the round great so you have to
have some visualization of that yes and
that's the only way of doing that death
moment is to ask if any item to render
wise it's just a list of numbers we've
got millions away the point is the image
you can't get the images
gone there's no way to get the image
because it's not official API is not
returning the image it's returning the
RAM but you wanted a kind of an image
map so there might be some kind of image
map hidden in that Ram without the idea
no it's not
it's they've left after image the whole
point is that it's not the image okay so
we're just saying that this it's a hacky
side-channel to like visualize this no I
don't understand why it helps you at all
and visualizing the ram the ram is just
a bunch of numbers it doesn't help you
because it shows you the image shows you
the image that you that is now gone
there's no other way of getting the
image if you didn't ask for that Ram
representation which is good for
learning
there's no way to observe it well that's
just because of some problem with that
framework because you have to be able to
get both I mean you should be able to
get both yeah we should just ask them so
if we hook this up our souls I think we
would ever see goes to do this but okay
but why don't we just ask them if
there's a way to do this maybe they have
something called RAM image something or
other v1 they will give both but we
shouldn't have some giant hack just for
the sake of getting that I mean I think
this will be a generic problem with
environments that we don't control sure
they can put up all kinds of random
windows on somebody's screen they can
you know erase the hard drive on a
computer it's not under our control sure
exactly since we're talking about state
should we call it observation because
it's a bit more general I'm thinking
about some future environment where
there's some hidden I mean there's some
state that we don't observe that that's
a good point and actually you call it
yourself of the observation space just
before so instead of state
representation I mean if you're going to
call it I mean personally I like state
representation if that's what it is
I was think there's also before right
when you do an action you return or is
it just a preposition what was it before
is a representation here I would I don't
know it would be natural that you
execute an action and you get black and
observation right along with reward and
it's over or not yeah well what about
when you initialize it you don't really
initialize an observation that's weird
no look why don't we say representation
doesn't say whether it's the state or
anything else because that doesn't
commit it itself to the fact that it is
a full representation of the state we
need to be I think it I think it's okay
I figured it it is I think we should
call it representation
no it's observation is not gonna cut it
it's obscure I mean that's what's
happening right we observe stuff
happening as alignment but not if we're
setting it to begin with
why not we're not setting it there are
we we could be setting it by conscious
state no you cannot you can just reset
everything you cannot set to a
particular state right so it's like in
general your country that I mean I would
see in this case you could do that if
you wanted to like I mean you could
implement that singular word
observations suggest that's just one of
it whereas this is some bizarre by truck
numbers observations but it doesn't
provide a way to set the state all right
so we could watch the state observed
state I was about to say that yes
right simultaneously I think that's
actually the most reasonable the ones
that I've seen here okay observed stage
so stitch is what you see in what you
hear observed state I think so they
observed I mean it suggests that there's
something related to observations and it
might not be the whole thing yeah and it
gives the idea that it's some state
representation which is correct um I
don't see a problem with this thing
about using the extra arguments there I
think it might be that you want sit down
there under extra arguments that seems
okay to me there's a way to do that you
might want to collect them as
Association or at least allow that
possibility but I think this is fine so
no ICS so like having your heart pain
association yeah yeah game goes to
whatever game is bad thing I see like
maybe system system or environment yeah
whatever you want to call it environment
okay fine I quite like having an
association form as well okay it's easy
to pass as well
okay so then okay just quickly but these
things before we get to that so the
state representation so which is the
state straight yep there's ended and
reward so I think ended I don't like
Enders
I think completed this better I don't
think that's the right thing because I
think completed might suggest that this
particular cycle has completed as
opposed to being somehow a synchronous
terminated kind of shades of robot
comprising robot uprising but that's
what this is all about um
terminated is better than ended also
people do talk about terminal stick it's
in the literature so it's it resonates
with okay um wait a second wait a second
the other possibility would be to say
running or um I mean this terminated
thing seems very negative in some sense
um what about active I think it's quite
and it's quite ambiguous yeah hum
episode ended the champion that people
use often um okay terminators the best
that I can think of right now
episode ended is hopeless something like
you know same time do they still have
that and back when I watch television
like 30-something years ago it was
always you know um same same time same
channel next week or something maybe
they don't say that anymore I'm probably
out of date never mind
um I mean no one watches TV anymore so I
wouldn't know well um we have completed
or finished I think those are even more
obscure um I mean we got to say what it
is and observed state
I think termination is as good as we're
gonna get and you want to use reward
I think reward is yeah I think yeah okay
it's fine it's everywhere okay terrific
okay and then this step fine
I should thus be I think that was fine
okay okay so there's a few questions and
we also wanted to know about this wolf
may I dream whether that's the right
name for it and it's not obvious to me
that it is good question yes what do we
call the other examples of devices we
have some sample devices like we have a
random walk device and things there's
like Arduino no no no I mean there's
bring up the documentation for a list of
devices there are ones that we use as
examples that are pure it's a sort of
abstract devices what are you doing
sure why should I share Shaun sorry I
was only sharing one window I know I
could see that um okay this is a version
documentation search does not work
hopefully that will be fixed let's go
back to the production version
you
okay hmm that's interesting so the ones
that are listed here do not include some
of our own sort of virtual devices look
random signal demo I don't know why we
don't because that's very related to
this
okay what I'm saying yes but I guess I
don't know why that thing is not doesn't
have a documentation page
um
it's not obvious that I mean how many of
these do we expect to have and how would
we hook up a generic system modeler sir
Alfred goodness sake one and earth is
that
well anyway okay so but this for
instance right we should be able to take
a system model like this
you
and I don't know exactly how you
instrument it
but this has clearly has a state oh
great let me run it in the current
version
I'm saying this this has some kind of
state while these looking and I think
you just need to ask the system modeling
people I mean this is a cool thing
because it will allow us to actually
take you know run machine learning
basically against any system
so as long as you set it up in the right
way that it has things like a reward and
whatnot yeah well I'm gonna go to you've
got to define that for these things I
don't know how you define that but but
Tim I think that's up to the humans to
define that but these what these provide
is a rich you know set of things worth
stuff happens with them in the world so
to speak yes exactly right so this will
have parameters that you can change I
don't even know what the you know you
can look this up I mean we could we
could get somebody from that I think not
perhaps not today but look you know
there's parameter of names parameter
values those are parameters you can
change etc
interesting what I mean this will be a
very fun sort of thing to make some
environments what's the similar it was
like now the question is do they need to
be device environments I mean it's clear
that you need a device mechanism I mean
I'm kind of thinking that this should be
more you know caught Pole example if
you're really just gonna use it as an
example because I think the system model
of thing is going to be the source of
basically all of our examples in the end
it's it's a rich source of real-world
stuff of you know virtual real world
stuff so to speak
especially that nowadays reinforcement
learning is almost only done on
simulated systems yeah well it's a big
nuisance to actually make the robot and
so on
so my suggestion would be for this
specific case that you have here just
call it an analogy
to this random signal gent demo call it
like COD poll demo
yes you have an objection to that ah I
don't have a mass ejection - that's so
the only thing is that it's so for
opening our gym it'll make sense to have
the sort of name spacing oh sure yeah
that's fine
that's opening there that's an external
device that's a generic external device
and there's a sub cases of it okay so in
this case what would happen is every
extra reinforcement learning environment
would be would get its own sort of class
which is that yeah yeah I think so but I
mean just call it simulated court poll
or something it's a device I mean I
don't know by the way I'm surprised this
doesn't go to a guide page I guess there
aren't enough of these yet
um yeah I mean I I think we're not even
listing these example things here I tell
what we would list in connected devices
we would have to list as a device type
this open AI Jim yes exactly
okay but these other ones here like GPIO
the way that opens a particular
one on earth okay so that's a single
GPIO object that gets opened and then
this is the specification of what sub
case of GPIO we are we're looking at
yeah or some parameters that you using
it's a little bit weird unfortunately
that that the open a item each different
elements of the Jim potentially requires
separate external set up correct
uh not really they can run with the same
setup okay so they have a completely
uniform interface which was the design
of this thing someone on the livestream
is by the way pointing out that the
system model or examples already have an
inverted pendulum I think we really need
to get hold of somebody from that team
and understand I've did this hookup I
think the hookup is going to be very
easy yeah probably I mean it should be
for simple systems like then give an
opinion of them you probably want to use
sister modeler like we've got a
super-fast compiled version of this
thing it allows you to trained real
quickly
yeah well this is also very fast the
system all our stuff is also fast it's
also compiled but I agree I mean I think
the
ultimately is gosh I hate the way this
works but anyway I mean ultimately what
we want to be able to do and that what
would this look like to do essentially
reinforcement learning on this thing
here it has certain parameters right so
I think there's a very simple thing that
we should do for this which is that we
expose an easy way of making a
reinforcement learning environments by
the way we could offer the open air I
guys access to this thing too we hadn't
thought of that that's true um
okay anyway so that there a bunch of
parameters here that you can change yeah
right
and it's easy to specify them
how this how this actually gets mapped
into the actual machine learning stuff
how do you do that do you have an
example of that I don't have it on me
now but roughly what do you do
so roughly at the moments the only way
of doing this is with net rain good and
I was in the future you know you will
have a some automated function but for
net rain you have you know you basically
have some environment that you set up
and net rain it has a callback function
as the so there's like the second
argument of nutrient there's a I think
the fifth form of net rain which is the
generator syntax so yeah the one that
calls the function f during training to
produce batches of train data so
basically the user has to write that
function f and that function f samples
what does actions based on the network
that you've currently gotten so and then
use that as Train days how do you get
the network you've currently got that's
the support that we added in 12 okay so
that then the function f is fed as an
argument the current state of the
network precisely okay and then it's up
to the user to iterate that over the you
know to do actions with it and then you
use that data as the next training step
but so the plan is to have some kind of
reinforcement learn type function that
simply takes
[Music]
I mean I don't quite understand how that
well go ahead what what um
is that right amid some reinforcements
learn thing where the goal is to like
increase the reward or some such other
thing you specify the goal and you
specify the system that you are learning
on so to speak you specify the network
is that right eventually yes I mean we
haven't we don't have much design for
that thing yet but the design would look
like it's just the implementing it would
be very very hard
why is it it's quite uh I know it's a
big complicated art but I'm saying given
that you specify you know on that which
you might get completely wrong
you know if you by hand specify the
neuron that the plumbing of how to feed
the feedback you know get the feedback
back in seems fairly straightforward
isn't that true yes I think I would
agree thoughts now I mean I don't know
does this also relate to the unity like
absolutely so unity is one of the main
environments for reinforcement learning
okay so who knows how to hook up the
unity link to reinforcement learning
stuff I have not any chance to look at
that yeah it's like you know see link
has unity has a reinforcement learning
environment set it should be pretty easy
once we've got unity link so that we
have unity like unity like this bottle
version 12 finally been cool that might
be very easy okay so we've got two major
hookups here the system modeling I mean
clearly all these things will only be
nice once we have a true reinforcement
learning function but we've got two
great sources that's true um they're
various questions on our live stream
might as well ask you guys um will there
be better ways to hyper parameter
searching and twelve
somebody asks this is important in
Bayesian reinforcement learning
so I'm sorry snow you know we've been
changing our minds on if we provide an
actual tool to do a perimeter search at
some point we're going on this side and
I saw the point was like oh well we can
do these things with any minimize and
things like that that's still open
question choice
are there any deep queue networks being
added to the repository I don't know
what deep queue means so the answer is
it's so there's two different approaches
to doing reinforcement learning or two
major ones
there's Q learning and there's policy
gradient learning okay
so the question is like are we gonna
provide things you know they've been pre
trained on things like Atari games
whatever I think it'll be very easy for
us to add this repository once once
again we've got some trains so one of
things you want to do is in the
documentation examples you want to have
for the state of the art methods
implemented it's called PPO and we
definitely want to train that on some
Atari games and I guess why not just put
that in the repository that now if it
strange seems like a good idea to me our
next thing would be nice to have the a3c
algorithm I also don't know what that is
[Music]
do you know yes so it's a very famous
asynchronous reinforcement learning
algorithm so probably we're not gonna
have any asynchronous things happening
4:12 almost certainly well so you know
it's not good to have any things
happening for 12 so that's for the
future so uncommon on a live stream that
sometimes it's called done instead of
ended card instead of terminated I don't
I think done is even more obscure done
error false is even more obscure than
Terminator or false
can you demo a random agent in Doom
instead of a cot pole
I hope if I don't think so so it's a
pity because I think Jim is in the
opening I am but again I could have I
could have done on that if external
evaluator was working right now
fair enough what is wrong with external
evaluator today it just fails okay but
is it knowing is somebody fixing it yeah
carrot is worthless okay fine
let's see I don't see how
would currently support training Multi
network reinforcement learning models
yeah well that's I think that was the
discussion about by hand having to
feedback having to give the training
Zeca synthesize training data by hand
he's mentioning it so there's some
methods that have lots or they've got
multiple different agents that are
acting at the same time or there's lots
of networks that are involved and that
we don't support of moments we only have
one network so as long as you can put it
in that form then it'll work and for
things you know like you know opening
eyes recent dota player for example was
in that form yes and that's also
important for things like cans and
whatnot so that that whole story has to
come together will go together
bread pudding maybe an association as
the specification of the network yeah as
a collection of net-net graphs and that
chains and things yeah that's one idea
yet they in Sebastian has a Gouda
nothing went quite some on our live
stream comments terminated sounds more
like aborted as opposed to ended yeah
that is true
yeah I think that's actually not a bad
point it's true it's like someone the in
action where it kind of was just over
exactly it just ended it's just done
mmmm come back to already running
true/false while it's not ready it's not
running because it's some it's waiting
for you to do something what would be
the qualifier how about this how about
status goes to you know running and
ended so the negative of that I mean it
doesn't make checking a slightly harder
like you always put these in some loops
and it's quite nice to have a true or
false flag but it's not the major thing
so status what would be the analogous
thing for a scheduled task for example
what do we call that
scheduled tasks does have a such a task
object she interrogated tasks object I
think there is a status
status running waiting etc well okay
there's more and more cases
in fact it has five cases I think it's
finished is finished here that's quite
neutral doesn't sound like something bad
happened yeah I think finished is not
bad fine
that's still very weird I wish there was
another word like if you could say you
know the run or the or something what is
it that is
look what I would a game I mean it is
actually ended not finished there's a
different notion there it's not even
obvious in many environments like when
is a robot well a robot could be
finished because it fell off a cliff for
something yeah exactly
right but the robot is not good
generically going to be ended it could
be a max time I mean it will be the next
time in this city maybe or somebody
switched it off or you know finite
episode right I mean you need I guess we
just don't know about device so we could
anything I think so I mean it can you
know the robot go flapping around the
world I'm doing what it does and I don't
think there's an ocean
[Music]
I mean you know system active is somehow
I think the notion there
of things active or is it I don't know I
don't know I mean part of the reason
this is hard to name is cuz we don't
really know quite what we're naming
which discontinued work
what it is how can a robot be
discontinued
it's not referring to the robot is
referring to the task that is doing so
the task is finished or ended with
something not the robot is finished
complete completes what a complete is
that it's you know it could complete the
task but there's other ways of it not
being finished or being you know like
falls off the cliff it hasn't completed
the tasks that are supposed to be doing
but it's in a state with you know it's
done like it's not gonna be doing
anything more look from this discussion
ended seems to me to be the least
hopeless of these names
none a terrific but that seems the least
untrue you know
but in the case where we have many
different observation like yeah for
example the image and whatever else we
can observe would we put many keys in
our session I would assume so for the
observed state yeah I think that's that
I mean the state representation would
just be an association it's now called
observed state okay
in a way the fact that it's over or not
is kind of an observation
well no it's an interpretation like the
robot sees you know it senses sense many
things but you're putting an
interpretation on that we could go
touring and we could say halted
you
again it kind of implies an action no no
no I think end it is the least hopeless
I think it's what we should go with the
task has ended all right we need the
complete circle we indeed you know it's
a mess right when you have Turing
machines you can have you know a whole
state or you can just decide the thing
is halted when it you know when the head
reaches some position all kinds of other
things it's kind of a nasty piece of
matter information
sure yeah I mean you can also you don't
have to like you know in tasks don't
have to even ever end
well right okay and it ended I think it
is for now okay um we can consider this
particular task has ended now um okay
anything else we need to cover in this
meeting nope
okay um for those on the livestream we
are about to go to a facilitation review
which I think has all kinds of
interesting things in it um I don't know
do you still have five minutes yes okay
so the questions if you look at the
questions that I've got the bottom so
just the naming you mean we'll never
have one which is the image why is it a
cart pole by the way why isn't it called
an inverted pendulum is there some
convention in this community that calls
it a cart pole pole anyway that's a pole
in a cart and the cart has to balance
the pole oh-whee comes from engineering
cool trophy so this is this book that is
like the sort of Bible of reinforcement
learning and I think they named this car
pool and like every I Jim just copied
this example from that book okay well so
you suggesting that the this naming
you're suggesting there's one way you're
learning from the image or watch so yeah
so I guess there could be a setting as
well so when you're creating the device
that could be like a completely
different things right a minute in look
we have to think for the future what are
we going to do with system model
cuz that's the more generic case
honestly this thing is some demo right
and we should call it a demo we should
call it whatever you were describing
that pole simulated caught pole desert a
couple I think it's fine
demo it yeah all right simulated caught
pole that's fine similar to car pole and
simulated caught pole image I suppose if
you really want to do that that's what I
would do I mean this is this is a I
consider this just a starter type thing
because the real version of this is
going to be you can give some arbitrary
but really complicated system model
thing that represents some you know
drone that you're trying to fly
and you know and because the sister
model thing has the ability to have you
know gusts of wind in there and all
kinds of stuff
you
should we use name versioning for gas
masks so in this case it doesn't matter
like carpools not got change no we're
not worried about it I mean again for
sister modeler but if an you know
versions of like this better wind that
is like it's modeling the wind slightly
better for one version than the other
yeah but I mean that's the same thing as
you load a package or something it might
be a better package I mean that's that's
a more general versioning issue I this
is straightforward to deal with in my
opinion okay um but if you can yourself
try and get some meeting set up with a
system model people I think they'll be
good
and I also don't know what the
relationship is between the unity stuff
I know that there has been some work on
the connection between the Unity link
and the system model of stuff
okay another thing system model has used
Unity link to render some things so
there must be some way of connecting
those um and that's your ultimate you
know pop-up window instead of having
some random piece of you know external
graphics you can have some pop-up you
know unity thing where it pops up this
thing that you know it's like you're
you're watching at which version of a
video game or something and it's some
maybe it seemed more than that maybe
they maybe they should have that for for
twitch instead of just watching a a kind
of a screen image of a in eSports or
something maybe you should have
something where you get a networked
version of unity so that you can go and
walk around the game for yourself even
as people are throwing hurling whatever
they perlers each other in these games
um alright
that that's my hope my best thought for
that it will be kind of interesting I
wonder if unity supports essentially the
the I think it must do the sort of force
there that I know it does the force
scripting of a Unity instance that's one
of the things it does so effectively you
could be playing it the series of
actions for the game and you as the
viewer get to do sort of the some kind
of weird VR experience so that you're
kind of walking around the game even as
it's being played
for Wordsworth okay very quickly can we
look at it as a way to describe action
space I just want to see if it's
compatible with that no it's lower slow
it was just the area action space I just
want to see if it's compatible with you
know active learning Bayesian
optimization thing discrete space
continue so Q it is a in the region its
region okay then it's fine is that
compatible yeah yeah there's some extra
way to define space and by an
optimization and so on
but these are included so what's good
okay sounds good all right talk it's you
listen and okay thanks